if you tried to have sex in the pool
you know that's not easy hey guys I'm
off the grid for August but Whoopi
Goldberg oh whoopee why didn't you take
the month off it would have refreshed
you and you wouldn't have done this you
know sex on the beach is overrated
sex both
because you know if you tried to have
sex in the pool
you know that's not easy
because you're trying to go up the hill
and you're getting resistance
from the water yeah that is within
oh my gosh okay
because when you're in the pool you are
surrounded in the water right have you
ever tried to put anything
ratchet now he's gonna send us the
commercial oh you trying to move me on
now right you you tell me you tell me
get engaged in the conversation then I
start to get a case that you want me to
stop talking
all right next topic I was learning
things yeah yeah yes well these are
things you already know that you maybe
don't know that you know because you
haven't done it for a long time oh or
maybe never did it I don't believe that
if you've never done any of these things
that are in my brain right now I'm a
Natural Born Blonde but this is the next
time you're at home
yeah gotta go dig on we'll be right back
thank you